la partie toujours dans l'idée que le
tertiaire c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas nécessairement à l'abri des
émissions gaz à effet de serre vous avez
ici un autre exemple de bilan carbone
qui concerne un organisme qui s'appelle
le british council et le british council
c'est l'équivalent britannique de
l'alliance française je sais pas si vous
connaissez l'alliance française
l'alliance française est un organisme
qui a pour mission de favoriser les
échanges culturels alors favoriser les
échanges culturels sera toujours été en
général que les gens puissent se parler
et que les gens puissent se parler avec
les moyens de transport modernes ça
revient pour l'essentiel à les mettre
dans un avion
donc cet organisme qui emploie
essentiellement des gens qui sont assis
dans un bureau dans le 7e arrondissement
en fait le poste principal de son bilan
carbone
c'est les moyens de transport qui sont
utilisés par les bénéficiaires des
bourses qui ont été distribués par cet
organisme
d'où à l'évidence une marge de manoeuvre
si on commence à s'intéresser à la
question de la réduction qui va ou qui
devront en priorité porter sur ce genre
de choses
vous voyez bien que si vous en revenez à
la halle à comment dire à la raison
d'exister à la raison même s'il vous
plaît si vous en revenez à la raison
même d'exister de ce genre d'organisme
son fonctionnement dans un monde dans
lequel la mobilité et se met à être
beaucoup plus gêné qu'avant sera
nécessairement impact et un après vous
retrouvez encore les moyens de transport
dans le fonctionnement de cet organisme
dans les émissions qui sont liées aux
déplacements de ses salariés donc en
gros si vous mettez boutabout les gens
qui bénéficient des bourses et les gens
qui travaillent sur place
et bien vous allez vous retrouver
avec 80% de démission qui sont
nécessaires entre guillemets pour que
cet organisme puisse fonctionner donc là
vous est typiquement dans un cas de
figure dans lequel vous vous dites j'ai
affaire à des gens dans un bureau est en
fait dans un monde dans lequel les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont
économiquement pénalisés et vous allez
voir dans pas longtemps que c'est à ça à
ce genre de réflexion que le bilan
carbone nous aide à réfléchir s'il vous
plaît c'est la dernière
après vous êtes libre jusqu'à jeudi de
l'intérieur réalisé un peu donc le
courrier que dans un monde dans lequel
la mobilité se met avec contraintes et
bien cet organisme là va nécessairement
devoir repenser son rôle et sa mission
après vous allez trouver quelque chose
auquel on pense pour tout naturellement
quand on a un bureau chauffer qui est le
chauffage et on va trouver également
quelque chose auquel on pense pas
naturellement
mais enfin vous normalement maintenant
vous devriez commencer à qui concerne la
rotation du parc informatique
donc le remplacement périodique des
ordinateurs avec lequel les gens
fonctionnent nemours yeux que encore une
fois c'est pas le pass qui domine donc
là j'aurais pu prendre comme exemple une
agence de voyages cette barre là aurait
été encore plus élevée
si si j'avais pris cet exemple là alors
maintenant vous êtes à la place du
directeur de cette organisation
vous vous dites je veux anticiper la
contrainte ou je veux faire quelque
chose d'utile pour que les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre baisse
eh bien vous voyez que peut-être que le
plus rapide
enfin le plus intéressant faire après ce
délai ça n'est pas de demander aux gens
d'en finir et qu'au verso c'est tout
simplement de vous demander comment est
ce que vous pouvez favoriser des
échanges culturels entre la france et la
grande bretagne avec des gens qui
prennent d'autres choses que l'avion
donc vous allez tomber sur une réflexion
qui va moins concerné les vis et les
boulons et les astuces techniques et j'y
reviendrai un peu plus tard plus
concernés la manière de fonctionner
l'organisation générale vous avec par
exemple si la quantité d'argent
distribué équivalente plutôt que de
financer ndoye âge d'une semaine vous
financez m sur 2 séjour de deux semaines
eh bien vous avez dit viser les
émissions de déplacement par deux a duré
six jours identiques
ça c'est pas de la technique
c'est typiquement de l'organisation et
j'y reviendrai plus tard en fait une
bonne partie des solutions entre
guillemets à notre affaire vous allez
vous rendre compte qu'elle ne réside pas
elle ne résoud pas dans simplement de la
technique ça fera toujours extrêmement
difficile de trouver une solution
satisfaisante à ce problème sans toucher
à l'organisation
ce qui tue votre manière de dire en
creux que si on attend que le problème
se résorbe tout seul eh bien il se
résoudre à tout seul notamment en
impactant plus ou moins fortement et
plus ou moins désagréablement les
organisations auxquelles nous sommes
habitués
voilà maintenant un autre exemple qui
vous illustre le fait que la noblesse de
l'objet social ne supprime pas la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
c'est pas parce que je fais quelque
chose qu'on considère comme étant
socialement utiles que nécessairement on
n'utilise pas d'énergie pour ça et que
ce fait on est assuré de pouvoir
continuer à exister à l'avenir quel que
soit l'état du monde
en france les dépenses de santé
représentent un peu plus de 10% du
produit intérieur brut c'est à dire de
l'activité économique du pays
aux états unis on est plutôt aux
alentours de 20% si vous considérez que
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
le pib sont homothétique ça veut dire
que en france un peu plus de 10 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
donc de la consommation d'énergie
fossile est liée au système de soins
parce que vous avez à l'évidence besoin
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre pour
fabriquer l'acier qui va vous servir à
fabriquer votre scanner votre appareil à
la mène où votre scalpel ou votre
seringue gens voulaient vie de la
seringue
vous avez besoin de chauffer les
hôpitaux mais vous avez besoin d'énergie
pour fabriquer les compresse les
médicaments etc en bref vous avez besoin
d'énergie aussi pour faire fonctionner
les ambulances les hélicoptères et que
le chirurgien viennent en voiture dans
l'hôpital quand il a besoin d'être
appelé en urgence d'une manière générale
le système de soins aujourd'hui et
dépendants de l'énergie fossile dans
d'autres tels qu'ils les bigorneaux et
d'autre des émissions qui sont associés
alors là j'ai pris un exemple qui est un
exemple peu atypique qui n'illustre pas
le système de soins français tout
simplement parce que probablement il n'y
a pas d'hopital qui est fait son bilan
carbone donc pas d'exemple à vous
proposer
mais par contre j'ai un exemple à vous
proposer sur une antenne de médecins
sans frontières à leur médecin sans
frontière et probablement quelque chose
qui dans votre esprit a une bonne cote
vous allez vous dire médecins sans
frontières quand même ça serait
dégueulasse que le fait qu'ils en aient
des problèmes sur le pétrole et un
impact sur les missions de médecins sans
frontières aussi y en aura quand même
parce que même une activité encore une
fois qu'on considère aujourd'hui comme
étant socialement utiles si le le coût
de ce qui me permet de fonctionner
devient excessif marie s'arrêtera
fonctionner où elle fonctionnera plus la
même manière alors c'est quoi les
émissions de cette antenne de médecins
sans frontières à haïti à l'époque où je
les housses j'ai fait ce
ce petit truc à est bien le premier
poste c'était le recours au fret aérien
pour faire venir tout ce qui était
nécessaire donc les scalpels les
compresses de médicaments etc
un deuxième poste concerné le groupe
électrogène diesel qui permettait de
fournir l'électricité au bloc et à
l'antenne médicale
un troisième poste concerné la
fabrication du matériel et des
médicaments qui étaient utilisés sur
place voilà vous voyez on commence à
rentrer dans dur en ce sens que si j'ai
pas le droit de mettre autant ou si ça
devient trop cher des maîtres tout ça
comment est-ce que je m'organise pour
pouvoir toujours continuer à offrir des
services médicaux alors une forme de
réponse est demandé aux médecins rester
plus longtemps à grandpré moins souvent
en france une autre femme de réponse
peut être de d'acheminer une partie du
stock par bateau une troisième force de
réponse peut être de mettre des panneaux
solaires parce que laure l'occurrence la
des panneaux solaires c'est quand même
plus efficace qu'un groupe électrogène
diesel offre ça fait moins d'émissions
dans tous les cas de figure vous voyez
que il ya à la fois des astuces
techniques entre guillemets et des
choses qui nécessitent de toucher à
l'organisation
si vous demandez aux médecins de rentrer
deux fois moins souvent chez lui on
touche à l'organisation hood est plus
sur une composante purement technique
voici un autre exemple très mauvais pour
votre foi qui est un producteur de
spiritueux savent et spiritueux c'est
des trucs qu'il faut consommer avec
modération
y'a même des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans la fabrication de l'alcool
mais là dedans il y en a alors là c'est
un exemple particulièrement intéressant
parce que il y en a à des endroits où
alain ah vee vous vous y attendez pas en
premier truc auquel vous vous attendez
probablement c'est que pour faire des
alcools forts il faut distillés de
congrès à la production d'un alcool fort
c'est exactement comme la production
d'un biocarburant sauf que ça rentre pas
exactement dans le même réservoir
vous commencez par faire une espèce de
vin à des fins et même du vin avec du
raisin sauf que c'est pas dur exemple
j'ai besoin de raisins très bonne
qualité vous destinez le vin en question
pour faire d autres vies et cce de vie
que vous allez a semblé laisser vieillir
et c'est pour faire des choses diverses
comme du whisky ou quand même du cognac
ou comme et adhérents alors la
destination bien évidemment se fait en
utilisant de l'énergie
donc vous allez retrouver quelque chose
dans le bilan carbone qui concerne ce
processus lent mais après vous allez
trouver un deuxième truc auquel moi je
m'attendais pas du tout quand j'ai fait
ça et les gens que j'avais en face de
moi pas plus qui est que la viticulture
qui est utilisé pour faire des
spiritueux est en général une
viticulture qui est comment dire bien
pousser bien productive dans laquelle on
va utiliser les engrais c'est beaucoup
moins vrai pour les vins aoc et la
fabrication de ces engrais est à
l'origine de la grosse barre que vous
avez là alors il faut savoir que les
engrais azotés qui sont actuellement
utilisés en agriculture sont fabriqués à
partir de gaz naturel
et quand on vous parle de la
civilisation hydrogène chez les gens qui
fabrique des engrais la dg dieu la plus
grosse production d'hydrogène dans le
monde
c'est le début de la chaîne de
fabrication d'ammoniaque qui lui même va
servir à faire derrière ce qu'on appelle
les engrais azotés
c'est à dire des ammonitrates oubliez
donc la production d'hydrogène
on sait faire secret bien faire en
craquant du méthane ça fait plein de co2
et ça utilise plein d'énergie fossile
c'est ça que vous allez retrouver dans
cette barre là c'est ça que vous allez
retrouver dans cette barre là et du lot
d'une manière générale je vous l'avais
déjà dit mais je vous le redis dans
l'agriculture qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
conventionnel mais qui des
conventionnels que depuis cinq ans
puisque les tracteurs les engrais de
synthèse ça date d'à peu près d'une
cinquantaine d'années le premier poste
de dépense énergétique à l'hectare quand
vous faites pousser du blé ou du maïs
c'est la fabrication des engrais pas des
anglais n
mais j'aurais adopté donc ça c'est ce
que vous allez retrouver dans cette
barre là après vous allez ici retrouver
quelque chose de très particulier
malgré l'intitulé c'est les émanations
de protoxyde d'azoté qui font suite à
l'épandage des engrais azotés je vous ai
dit
que dans les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il avait des émissions de
protoxyde d'azoté est le plus gros poste
d'émission de protoxyde d'azoté sur
terre c'est la réduction des nitrates
d'une petite partie des nitrates plus
exactement qui fait suite à l'épandage
des engrais azotés dans les champs ça
correspond à ce bar là donc vous voyez
l'utilisation des engrais dans la
viticulture à nom est responsable de ces
deux gars là où est à l'origine de ces
deux gars là qui représente est de loin
le premier poste du bilan carbone de mon
producteur d'alcool ensuite vous allez
trouver un dernier post significatif qui
est que vous achetez rarement d'alcool
en vrac ou en tendant les mains comme ça
en général c'est contenu dans une
bouteille et la bouteille pour arriver
dans le magasin il a fallu la mettre
dans un carton et bien la production de
tous ces matériaux d'emballage re est
représenté par cette barre là alors
c'est toujours pareil si j'augmente le
prix de l'énergie ou si je mets une
contrainte sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre comment est ce que tout
ça va évoluer
alors vous pourriez me dire si
j'augmente suffisamment le prix des
énergies fossiles tout le sait la
récession économique
tout le monde est malheureux et les gens
boivent de plus en plus d'alcool ce qui
n'est pas faux donc il n'est pas
complètement sûr que cette activité-là
se portent de plus en plus mal il ya
qu'à voir ce qui se passe en russie
actuellement pour être convaincu du fait
que la cession peut être une très bonne
affaire pour quelques producteurs
particuliers et en particulier celui là
enfin il n'empêche que si on essaye de
réfléchir à ce que peuvent être les
marges de manoeuvre qui s'offre à une
activité de cette nature
et bien voilà l'ordre dans lequel vous
devriez en toute bonne logique prendre
les chantiers si vous voulez respecté la
hiérarchie des post première chose que
vous allez commencer par regarder c'est
pas le papier consommé par les gens qui
imprime recto verso
c'est la quantité d'engrais utilisé dans
la viticulture
donc là pour changer ce genre de choses
c'est très simple il faut une génération
si vous voulez vous attaquer à la
manière dont des agriculteurs pratiquent
leur activité
exactement comme si vous voulez vous
attaquer à la manière dont des pêcheurs
ou les ingénieurs des mines pratiquer
leur activité il vous faut une
génération
donc là
premier poste sur lequel vous devez vous
penchez c'est d'essayer d'avoir des
variétés qu'ils soient plus productives
avec moins d'engrais la deuxième chose
sur laquelle vous pouvez vous penchez
c'est diminuer d'énergie de distillation
alors là on n'est plus dans les vis et
les boulons qui vous sont familiers une
troisième chose sur laquelle vous
pourriez vous penchez et là vous allez
aussi tombé sur le comportement humain
de manière intéressante c'est que c'est
le seul en fait je me suis trompé dans
la barre la flèche du haut elle devrait
taper sur cette barre à cette flèche là
et devrait taper sur cette barre c'est
la fabrication des bouteilles et des
cartons ce ce que là vous allez entrer
frontalement en conflit avec les gens du
marketing qui vont vous dire pour que le
client on considère mon produit comme un
produit de luxe et qu'ils aient envie de
l'acheter il faut que ça tienne dans la
maintiennent dans la main et que ce soit
lourd si vous voulez faire une bouteille
légère c'est techniquement possible
mais les clients dix ans une bouteille d
r j'en veux pas parce que c'est quelque
chose qui doit nécessairement de
mauvaise qualité pourriez très bien
mettre de la vodka ou du whisky dans une
petite bouteille en plastique
absolument et aucun autre pack technique
à sa tournée devant le champagne dans
une bouteille en plastique
il n'y a aucun obstacle technique à ça
par contre il ya les obstacles marketing
en ce sens que vous avez affaire à un
public qui ne voudra pas compte tenu de
ses connaissances sur le problème et
compte tenu de ses habitudes de votre
innovation technique et ça j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure quand je vous
parlerai de ma vision des métiers du
développement durable vous verrez que
c'est pas tout d'avoir une bonne idée
encore faut-il savoir la vendre savoir
la faire accepter et d'une certaine
manière préparer le terrain pour que ce
que vous considérez comme étant une
bonne idée ça soit aussi considéré par
les gens vous avez en face de vous comme
étant une bonne idée et souvent c'est
autre chose comme chemin de croix que de
simplement trouver sur le papier ce qui
permet de faire des choses intéressantes
là vous avez l'assiette des émissions
sur laquelle portent une marge de
manoeuvre à laquelle on va souvent pensé
qu'ils aient utilisé mon à voiture pour
aller au travail etc ou marcher à pied
et a de bonnes raisons de marcher à pied
ça c'est très clair
cela étant vous voyez que en termes de
vulnérabilité fort en termes de
dépendance aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre les gens qui prennent la
voiture pour venir travailler le matin
c'est pas le premier souci de cette
entreprise par contre ça peut être le
premier souci des gens qui y travaillent
si vous regardez ce qui est en train de
se passer actuellement vous avez un
certain nombre de salariés qui habitent
à 20 30 ou 40 km de leur travail qui
commence à vraiment souffrir à cause de
l'envolée récente des prix des
carburants alors vous ça vous concerne
pas puisque vous êtes des nantis
parisien comme moi mais paris sipa la
france et vous avez un certain nombre de
gens dans le pays qui aujourd'hui se
sont domiciliés à quelques dizaines de
km de leur travail
bien évidemment ils ont fait ça à une
époque où il voyait pas que le prix du
pétrole allaient monter un jour il
n'empêche que pour eux c'est leur
problème
il faut donc jamais perdre de vue que il
peut y avoir dans un bilan carbone des
postes qui semblent secondaires dans
l'analyse globale vue de l'entreprise et
qui peut l'être très important vu d'un
individu ou d'un porteurs d'intérêts
particuliers qui fait partie de la
chambre une des choses que vous pouvez
faire aussi et là c'est quelque chose
qui ne va pas seulement être de la
technique l'énergie de distillation est
proportionnelle au volume donc toi
l'utilisation des engrais est
proportionnelle aux volumes produits de
raisin donc in fine et au volume d'eau
de vie distillés dont le poids la
quantité de matériaux et que vous allez
utiliser pour les emballages donc la
corde le clown vert pour le flaconnage
et la quantité de carton pour
transporter et proportionnel le toit et
enfin les émissions qui sont liées au
fret sont proportionnelles le poids
donc là vous avez eue
marge de manoeuvre que vous pouvez avoir
envie d'explorer qui est de se dire
comment est ce que je peux vendre des
bouteilles qui va le plus cher en en
contenant moins ça peut être dans
certains cas de figure une porte de
sortie
vous voyez que là on est sorti des vis
et des boulons technique on est sorti
des vis et des boulons technique on
touche à ce qu'on appelle la politique
produit c'est à dire c'est qu'ils les
clients et qu'est ce que cherchent à
leur vendre et vous verrez que dans le
bilan carbone que je vais vous présenter
derrière et ce je vous ai déjà présenté
finalement quand vous poussez la logique
jusqu à son goût on en revient toujours
à cette question qui est dans un monde
dans lequel le flux physiques qui va me
coûter de plus en plus cher alors que ça
fait deux siècles qu'il me coûte de
moins en moins cher
c'est qu'ils les clients et de leur
emploi en leur disant qu a du reste
après vous avez des trucs sur lequel
vous pouvez vous pencher mais finalement
ça va être quelque chose de relativement
marginal et en particulier une des
choses qu'on voit très souvent dans la
presse comme étant la solution évidente
à tous nos problèmes c'est à dire
d'accroître le recours aux énergies
renouvelables
bah quand vous regardez ce genre de truc
vous vous rendez compte que c'est pas
vraiment la question
indépendamment de tout ce que j'ai pu
vous raconter jusqu'à maintenant encore
des jardins anglais
il s'agit de la direction générale de
l'énergie et des matières premières
c'est à dire un endroit où travailler un
certain nombre d'anciens de cette école
enfin quand je dis que je plaisante pas
des autodidactes comme vous ni comme moi
du reste mais c'est plutôt des x mines
donc vous allez trouver trois postes et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
représentatif des activités de bureau
d'une manière générale vous allez
trouver trois postes importants
le chauffage est là si vous voulez agir
sur ce poste eh bien
clairement il faut toucher ou bien la
température intérieure ou bien à
l'isolation des locaux et en ce qui
concerne la bureautique à la quantité
d'ordinateurs et à leur puissance que
vous mettez à la disposition des jambes
mais vous pouvez aussi toucher à
l'organisation
étant donné qu'une bonne partie de ces
gens en font du travail de bureau
gens ont des logements qui l'hiver est
chauffée même quand ils n'y sont pas et
bien vous pouvez vous dire que une
partie de ces gens peut très bien
travailler de chez eux une partie de la
semaine et à partir du moment où cette
organisation vous permet de diminuer à
due concurrence la surface de bureaux
chauffer dont vous avez 100 personnes
qui travaillent à plein temps et vous
passez à 100 personnes qui sont la
moitié du temps chez elle et la moitié
du temps chez vous et nous dit crocs
je divise par deux la surface chauffe et
je fais tourner les gens dans des
bureaux qui n'appartiennent plus à
pierre paul ou jacques
mais qui sont des bureaux dans lesquels
les gens viennent s'installer avec leurs
ordinateurs et les photos de leurs
gosses et quand ils s'en vont ils
reprennent le tout et c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui vient à leur place là vous
voyez que vous n'êtes plus dans une
situation dans laquelle la porte de
sortie elle est purement technologique
vous êtes de nouveau dans une situation
dans laquelle la porte de sortie entre
guillemets elle est technique au social
et même technico économiques ou sociales
être poste là vous avez
des déplacements de personnes donc les
déplacements de personnes très peu
d'émissions liés au domicile travail de
dgemp est situé boulevard vincent auriol
comme vous le savez tous et boulevard
vincent auriol c'est pas très loin d'ici
c'est très bien desservi par le métro
ils ont des employés qui habitent
essentiellement dans l'agglomération
parisienne pour les gens viennent en
transports en commun
donc il ya plus grand chose à gratter là
dessus par contre vous avez les cadres
qui prennent quelques fois l'avion dans
l'année et là c'est pareil la question
c'est est-ce que je peux baisser la
quantité d'avions qu'ils prennent dans
l'année alors il se trouve que si on met
les pieds dans le plat dans ce genre
d'endroit où dans une société les gens
peuvent avoir de raison de prendre
l'avion
la première c'est parce qu'ils ont
vraiment quelque chose à faire là oui
bon et la deuxième c'est parce qu'ils
ont envie se changer les idées
la deuxième raison est la troisième du
reste qui va avec la deuxième c'est
parce qu'ils accumulent des miles qui
leur permet à près de changer les idées
pendant les vacances
vous rigolez mais c'est je suis
absolument certain que si on supprimait
au système des miles on supprimerait une
bonne partie des voyages professionnels
c'est absolument évident donc vous avez
ici un problème à traiter
et là aussi vous voyez que si vous
essayez de traiter de manière purement
technique il ya pas de problème de
manière purement technique il ya des
milliers de réunions qui peuvent se
gérer et par visioconférence ou par mail
ou d'une manière qui n'a absolument rien
à voir avec le fait que l'on prenne
l'avion à tous à tout bout de champ 1 ça
ne supprimerait pas la totalité des
déplacements en avion c'est très clair
mais ça on supprime une partie
sauf que si vous prenez le problème
comme ça vous faites fausse route
parce que encore une fois une bonne
partie de la raison de monter dans un
avion n'est pas juste stricto sensu la
raison professionnelle
ça peut être autre chose là on retombe
sur ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
si vous cherchez à faire baisser ses
émissions
vous ne pouvez pas le faire sans
réfléchir sur le fonctionnement général
de l'organisation est ce qui motive les
gars et enfin en ce qui concerne les
immobilisations là vous avez une partie
où vous ne pouvez plus rien faire on
l'immeuble qui a déjà été construit ça
c'est clair que si on met fonderie
ça va faire en plus de carbone sous
terre par contre vous avez une question
qui se pose aussi sur la rotation du
parc informatique
parce que périodiquement vous renouveler
des ordinateurs est-ce qu'il faut se
faire plaisir à monsieur bill gates
autant qu'aujourd'hui où est ce que il
faut mettre un peu la [ __ ] douce et
considérer que parfois le dernier mach 1
x oz/t prime on s'en passera pour
l'instant et ça n'empêchera pas les gens
de fonctionner quand même ben là c'est
pareil
vous n'avez pas que des considérations
économiques ou techniques qui rentrent
en ligne de compte comme vous le saurez
quand vous serez dans la vie active des
goûts laisser des ingénieurs et des
techniciens quelque part dans un endroit
où il ya des diodes vertes orange et
bleu ils veulent toujours le dernier cri
toujours voilà et ça c'est une question
humaine c'est pas juste voilà tapas deux
derniers jeux vidéo machin chouette et
c'est une question humaine ça c'est pas
vraiment une question de fonctionnalités
donc voilà quelque chose qui vous permet
à la fois de constater que même dans une
administration ce que je vous ai déjà
dit mais je vous le redis il ya des
émissions est par ailleurs que la
manière à vous attaquer aux émissions et
bien ne n'est pas toujours simplement
une affaire de technique il on pourrait
presque dire que c'est rarement purement
une affaire de technique
là vous avez a contrario un cas de
figure très simple c'est un gestionnaire
de décharge alors un gestionnaire de
déchets pardon pas de décharge tiers de
déchets donc un gestionnaire de déchets
il faut deux chercheuses
il gère des incinérateurs et j'aime des
charges vous avez les camions qui
collectent les déchets vous avez
l'éclairage et le chauffage des
bâtiments d'exploitation de cet
opérateur et là vous avez deux choses
vous avez le co2 liées à la combustion
des matières plastiques et vous avez le
méthane qui s'échappent de la matière
enfin de matières organiques qui a été
enfoui et notamment du papier du carton
et des déchets alimentaires
là on allait quasiment qu'une chose à
faire c'est réfléchir à la manière dont
vous pouvez un capter le méthane et deux
parce que ça sera un peu plus compliqué
mais vous pouvez le faire aussi
récupérer le plastique pour en refaire
du plastique plutôt que de le brûler
dans un incinérateur
ça c'est un cas de figure dans lequel
l'organisation ou le problème
d'organisation il au moins interne
qu'externe
aujourd'hui vous avez vous est configuré
dans ce genre de société pour gérer le
problème d'une certaine manière
techniquement c'est très facile de le
gérer d'une autre manière
sauf que vous avez à l'extérieur des
gens parce que la gestion des déchets en
général c'est une mission pour laquelle
vous êtes mandaté par la collectivité
donc il faut que la collectivité accepte
que vous y preniez autrement vous pouvez
éventuellement avoir des problèmes de
partage des revenus qui change etc
mais enfin c'est un cas de figure on va
dire qui est techniquement plus simple
encore un exemple autres là vous avez
affaire une chaîne de télévision
alors une chaîne de télévision qu'est ce
qu'elle fait elle a besoin d'électricité
pour éclairer le présentateur du 20h et
un certain nombre d'autres personnes
elle a besoin d'envoyer deux
journalistes en reportage et que les
gens viennent travailler le matin elle a
besoin d'acheter du matériel pour de
prises de vues de prises de sons des
tables de mixage des services
informatiques etc etc que vous allez
retrouver à la fois là et là là c'est
pour la partie consommables et en
particulier la et finalement la grille
de programmes
et là vous allez trouver l'acquisition
du matériel qui est utilisé en interne
et qu'elle a besoin que les gens
allument leur télévision parce que faire
une chaîne de télévision si les gens
n'allume pas leur télévision c'est pas
facile
et à ce moment vous vous rendez compte
que l'essentiel des émissions
si vous prenez quelque chose de brut
c'est
l'utilisation de la télé lyon et encore
il ya un postulat qui n'a pas été pris
en compte qui est la fabrication de la
télévision et qui peut ne pas être
négligeable il ya certains cas de figure
dans lequel vous pouvez tout à fait le
relier à des programmes qui ont été
diffusées de manière discernable en
particulier quand il commence à y avoir
la coupe du monde de foot
eh bien vous constaté une augmentation
du nombre de ventes d'été est fade et
des ventes de téléviseurs
donc c'est bien parce que la chaîne va
diffuser le match de foot qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui achètent des
télévisions plus grande ou de meilleure
qualité ce par quoi pour remplacer ce
qu'ils avaient avant là il ya la
consommation d'électricité des
téléviseurs non pas des particuliers
s'il y avait la totalité des
particuliers ou non c'est juste le
téléviseur
absolument
cette se postera on peut le retrouver
dans le bilan carbone d'autres acteurs
de la chaîne mais c'est pas gênant un
bilan carbone c'est pas quelques cépages
briques de lego c'est à dire que c'est
pas quelque chose qui doit pouvoir sans
piles et les uns sur les autres sans
qu'il y ait de double compte ça illustre
la notion de dépendance
en fait vous allez trouver plein
d'acteurs économiques qui dépendent des
mêmes utilisations d'exhibition pardon
d'utilisation si je fais le bilan
carbone non pas de la chaîne de
télévision mais de monsieur arthur
monsieur arthur pour que sa société de
production puisse vivre
il a aussi besoin de cette barre là et
si je fais le bilan carbone d'un
fabricant de téléviseurs je vais
également retrouver ce truc là
et si je fais le bilan carbone de partie
je vais également retrouver cette barre
là donc c'est pas parce que vous allez
trouver les émissions dans un bilan
carbone d'un acteur donné que l'on va
pas les retrouver dans le bilan carbone
de quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'il peut y
avoir des tas d'acteurs distincts qui
dépendent d'un même processus
mais c'est pas gênant parce que encore
une fois le but d'un bilan carbone c'est
pas de produire un chiffre pour la
beauté du chiffre et derrière de les
empiler des uns sur les autres c'est
toujours pour répondre à une question
donc là la question vous vous poser est
la suivante je suis la chaîne de
télévision l'électricité se met à valoir
plus cher parce que les combustibles
fossiles valent plus cher et dans le
cadre du déplacement du prix de marché
de l'électricité
c'est vrai aussi pour l'électricité des
centrales nucléaires si personne ne fait
rien contre 1 et à ce moment la question
que vous posez c'est dans un monde dans
lequel électricité se met à valloire de
plus en plus cher est-ce que ce truc là
est en péril
ou pas ce qui revient à vous poser la
question qui est si l'électricité votre
plus en plus cher est ce que les gens
vont d'abord utiliser moins leur micro
ondes ou d'abord moi regarder la
télévision
ça ne veut pas nécessairement dire cette
barre là que vous allez vous en prendre
plein la figure
ça veut juste dire là vous avez un lien
de dépendance et vous devez vous poser
la question qui est est ce que ce lien
il va se matérialiser par une contrainte
économique supplémentaire
alors y avait un avenir ou non il ya des
fois où vous pouvez vous dire que nous
je vais vous donner un autre exemple
imaginons qu'on fasse le bilan carbone
de total est bien l'essentiel delà du
bilan carbone de total va se retrouver
dans cette barre à je suis total
j'extrais et jora fine des combustibles
mes émissions propre c'est 10 % des
émissions qui vont être engendrés par
les clients quand ils vont brûler les
combustibles en question maintenant
imaginons que le prix des hydrocarbures
augmente
est-ce que l'importance de cette barre
lâché total va mettre en péril mon
bénéfice c'est pas sûr
alors pour bien d'autres mécanismes
s'est partiellement oui notamment les
partages de rentrer avec les pays
producteurs mais c'est pas quelque chose
qui découle directement de l'examen de
cette barre là il suffit pas de regarder
cette barre là pour avoir la réponse à
votre question
le bilan carbone encore une fois il ne
va jamais vous donner la réponse prête à
l'emploi sur ce qu'il advient de votre
activité
à partir du moment où émettre des gaz à
effet de serre ou utiliser de l'énergie
va coûter de plus en plus cher par
contre il vous permet de vous poser des
questions que vous poseriez pas sinon
c'est bien comme ça qu'il faut le voir
c'est à dire qu'ils amènent des
questions auxquelles d'habitude on pense
pas si je prends aussi je prenais un
autre exemple qui est l'école des mines
et bien ce que je disais tout à l'heure
et qui n'est qu'à moitié une boutade
une partie importante des émissions de
l'école des mines c'est ça et c'est les
émissions dont vous allez dès prendre 20
une fois que vous serez dans des
entreprises ou des administrations
diverses et là on peut imaginer que dans
un monde dans lequel l'énergie votre
plus en plus cher ou les émissions sont
plus en plus contraintes les débouchés
vous avez aujourd'hui voulait dans la
plus demain ça sera plus et même ça
revient à dire que cette barre là là
pour le coup elle est porteuse d'une
question qui fait sens qui est où seront
les débouchés de demain dans un monde de
plus en plus contraints sur l'énergie
fossile
voilà donc c'est encore une fois il fait
vous sortir de la tête l'idée que
eux à une entreprise ou une collectivité
qui fait son bilan carbone est
responsable des émissions de son bilan
carbone c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est le lien de dépendance
encore une fois c'est de quoi est-ce que
je dépends alors cela étant c'est cette
chaîne de télévision veut contribuer à
la baisse des émissions mondiales de gaz
à effet de serre elle peut à la fois se
dire qu'elle va travailler là dessus et
là dessus donc par exemple ne pas céder
à son caméraman qui est vidé une fois la
caméra dernier cri chevelu laroque peut
très bien travailler avec celle que tu
actuellement ne pas céder à tel
producteur qui lui dit que ce faire une
émission valable il faut aller de
l'autre côté de la terre et transporter
253 personnes par avion mais elle peut
aussi se dire que elle va aller militer
à bruxelles pour que l'on impose des
normes plus sévères aux consommation des
téléviseurs
par exemple 1 c'est quelque chose qui
peut faire sens voilà donc cesser ses
destinées encore une fois à amener des
suggestions et des pistes pour l'action
jamais de réponse toute prête
ce serait trop beau mais par contre
souvent des questions qui n'ont pas été
formulées jusque ou pas ou pas de cette
manière jusqu'à lors autre exemple la
publicité et bien vous avez sur ce bilan
carbone qui est celui d'une agence de
pub qui imprime des prospectus
donc je prends des sosies de cary grant
et de marilyn monroe
je les mets sur des prospectus à côté
d'une cuisse de poulet à prix cassés et
je dépose sa dans les grandes surfaces
et bien une telle activité est
essentiellement une activité annexe de
la fabrication du papier essentiellement
question est ce que la publicité
survivre à un monde dans lequel produire
du papier ça vaut plus cher c'est pas
sûr en tout cas toutes les à lens n'y
survivront probablement quand nous pas
sous la forme sous laquelle il existe
actuellement ou peut être pas en aussi
grand nombre etc
par ailleurs si vous avez une
contraction générale du pouvoir d'achat
parce que comme je vous le disais
en ouverture de cette série de courts
l'énergie à bas prix c'est
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat et
l'énergie dont le prix augmente c'est la
contraction du pouvoir d'achat est bien
dans un monde dans lequel vous avez la
compaction du pouvoir d'achat peut-être
que les activités de publicité d'une
manière générale d'une seule big horn et
différemment ça c'est sûr et peut-être
qu'à sont pas aussi florissante mais
vous voyez que clairement ça pose des
questions qu'ont encore une fois on n'a
pas l'habitude de se poser et là vous
avez un industriel qui fait des biens
d'équipement un brin à l'industrie du
fait des biens d'équipement c'est quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui ne vend pas
directement ses produits au grand public
c'est quelqu'un qui en général vend ses
produits à d'autres acteurs d'une chaîne
qui précède le grand public par exemple
un cimentier c1 industrie c'est d'une
manière générale un industriel qui ne
vend pas directement au grand public ou
très peu il va essentiellement roja des
maçons et à des sociétés de btp
quelqu'un qui fait des tableaux de bord
et pour automobiles
il va pas vous les vendre en direct il
va les vendre à un constructeur
automobile bon voilà vous avez un
industriel donc qui fait des biens
d'équipement et il ya deux postes
importants
cet industriel le premier c'est les
matériaux qui rentre dans la composition
de ses produits
donc là il ya du boulot clairement pour
des gens qui se penche sur la question
pour savoir ce qu'il faut prendre des
matériaux dans les mêmes proportions et
caetera et il a un deuxième sujet qui
est sa logistique et sa logistique elle
mais elle met deux questions sur la
table la première c'est les moyens de
transport utilisés et la deuxième c'est
la localisation des usines versus et
marché il est évident que si vous avez
juste un site de production qui dessert
le monde dans son ensemble
vous n'avez pas la même logistique que
si vous avez des petits sites de
production avec des zones de chalandise
régional alors jusqu'à maintenant on a
fait en ce qui concerne les entreprises
exactement la même chose sur ce qu'on a
fait en ce qui concerne les personnes
c'est à dire que on a internationalisé
c'est ça la mondialisation à la
mondialisation et perdre n'est possible
que parce que le transport coûte de
moins en moins cher le jour où le
transport coûte de plus en plus cher il
ya une partie de la mondialisation qui
ne kiss kiss est très prospère donc là
vous avez deux questions qui sont posées
je fabrique comment je fabrique ou et je
distribue comment et puis vous avez une
troisième question qui est posée qui
n'était pas ici qui est à quoi ça sert
et est ce que les gens qui ne l'achète
aujourd'hui ils seront toujours aussi
florissant demain dans un monde sur
lequel il ya plus en plus de contraintes
d'une manière générale toutes les
numérations que je viens de vous faire
vous montre deux choses la première
c'est que c'est une démarche la
comptabilité carbone qui peut
s'appliquer à n'importe quel acte qui
peut s'appliquer absolument n'importe
quelle activité que c'est une démarche
qui amène à se poser des questions qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de se poser dans un
monde infini et dans lequel la bonne
question n'est pas est ce que
l'expansion est possible mais simplement
comment est ce qu'on la sueur
alors que le bilan carbone oblige à se
poser la question des limites à
l'expansion qui est évidemment quelque
chose qui n'est pas naturel dans les
activités économiques
alors qui normalement les un tout petit
peu pour vous puisqu'il s'agit rien
d'autre que d'une forme d'optimisation
sous contrainte sauf qu'il ya une
contrainte nouvelle qu'on n'avait pas en
tête jusqu'à maintenant et dont on est
obligé de tenir compte
le but du jeu une fille née est toujours
d'en arriver là c'est à dire j'avais des
émissions qui était un certain niveau
comment est ce que je fais pour que ces
émissions soient inférieures plus tard à
activité constante c'est toujours ça la
question et même comment est ce que je
fais pour qu'elle soit inférieure
activité croissante car en effet quelque
chose qu'il faut constamment garder à
l'esprit c'est que dans cette affaire la
manière dont on est classiquement
habitué à résonner dans un monde sans
limite
c'est que la réduction importante et
celle ci c'est à dire la réduction par
unité produite la réduction par unités
d'oeuvre
la réduction par uchida faire la
réduction par ceux ci la réduction par
cela alors que dans le monde contre un
qui est nôtre à la fois en ce qui
concerne l'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles et le changement
climatique
le vrai bon signal il est de faire
baisser la crème du haut c'est à dire la
consommation globale d'énergie fossile
et les émissions globales de gaz à effet
de serre et c'est bien celle là comme je
voulais a expliqué précédemment qui vont
finir par baisser de toute façon un jour
que ça nous plaise ou pas donc si nous
ne sommes pas capables de trouver un
moyen
faire baisser sa dans la joie et la
bonne humeur
alors ça se passera toute façon mais
probablement avec beaucoup moins de
joueurs et beaucoup moins bonne humeur
faire baisser ça on a toujours su faire
donc c'est passé à la question faire
baisser ça on a toujours su faire donc
ça n'est pas ça la question
la question c'est comment faire baisser
sa qui n'a pas cessé de croître depuis
le début de la révolution industrielle
si on oublie que le bilan carbone est
quelque chose qui permet de réfléchir
sur la contrainte globale et non pas sur
la contrainte unitaire on est passé
complètement à côté du problème
encore une fois le problème c'est
comment est-ce que je gère une ressource
qui est globalement fini et non pas
qu'ils aient fini par cafetière que je
produis où marchait ce que je produis ça
encore une fois on a toujours su faire
c'est facile comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure j'ai des enfants comme je
lé beaucoup dit jusqu'à maintenant
en fait l'un des intérêts de cette
approche c'est bien de se poser la
question qui est la suivante si je ne
fais rien qu'est ce qui se passe dans un
monde dans lequel la contrainte se
matérialisent tout seul ce qui va
notamment où probablement se traduire
par le fait que le prix des combustibles
fossiles ou la contrainte économique
mise sur les émissions d'accroître la
contrainte économique mission les
émissions elle peut se matérialiser
non seulement par une taxe mais par des
tas d'autres mécanismes
par exemple quand vous mettez une bonne
ça c'est quelque chose que l'on sait
faire dans un certain nombre de pays
industrialisés par exemple on dit une
voiture n'émettra pas plus de temps un
téléviseur ne consommera pas plus de
temps un bâtiment ne consommera plus de
temps au mètre carré et c'est ça hein
coûte 1 ce genre de choses ça coûte une
aime ça a toujours un coup tu pour celui
qui doit l'appliquer
toujours de même que quand on limite les
quantités produites ce qui peut arriver
aussi quand vous mettez des quotas ça
nécessairement un coût
il n'est pas explicite mais il existe je
précise coûte pour que l'on comprenne
bien qu'il s'agit pas de sens mais avec
le thé à la fin alors prévenir à la
première manière de se poser des
questions
à partir du bilan carbone vous avez la
possibilité et c'est là que ça commence
à devenir marrant de regarder qu'est-ce
qui en notes de grandeur est en jeu à
partir du moment où vous considérez que
le prix des hydrocarbures augmente dans
un bilan carbone
vous avez des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre abondé par une activité dans la
caisse dans lesquels vous pouvez
individualisé ce qui relève du co2 ce
que vous n'avez pas du co2 dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre une
fois que vous avez individualisé ce qui
relève du co2 ça veut dire que quelqu'un
quelque part a brûlé les des
hydrocarbures pour émettre ce co2 ainsi
vous avez du co2 dans la fabrication de
cet ordinateur en bilan carbone de cet
ordinateur
ça veut dire que quelqu'un quelque part
a vraiment brûler des combustibles
fossiles pour les bêtes sociaux de l'an
l'occurrence étaient des centrales à
charbon pour fabriquer des lectrices
rappelé produire l'électricité qui a
permis sont les composants plus
d'industries chimiques qui a besoin de
faire qui a eu qui a brûlé des
combustibles pour faire l'étape produits
dont on a besoin pour faire ça et c est
à ce moment vous pouvez vous dire
admettons que le prix des combustibles
fossiles augmente alors celui qui est
l'utilisateur direct des combustibles
voit ses coûts d'utilisation augmente et
toutes choses égales par ailleurs et à
ce moment là question vous vous posez
c'est est pour celui qui fait son bilan
carbone ou ses clients qu'est-ce que ça
devient qu'est-ce que ça devient vous
avez la réponse dans une évolution
économique récente qui est par exemple
la fabrication des voitures
vous êtes un fabricant de voitures et
bien le surcoût août
il n'est pas tellement pour vous en tant
que entreprises qui avaient des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
faire la voiture c'est là surtout se
matérialiser là vous êtes aussi pour
ceux d'entre vous qui suivent un tout
petit peu cette actualité
vous avez peut-être père et que sans que
cette general motors aux états unis qui
a très récemment fermer quatre usines ou
qui appuient activement très récemment
annoncé qu'ils allaient fermer quatre
usines qui fabriquait
les suv là vous savez les gros pick-up
et 4,4 américains parce que ces gens là
on achète de moins en moins dans un
contexte dans lequel ça ça augmente donc
vous est typiquement dans un cas de
figure dans lequel le bilan carbone de
general motors fait il ya quelques
années
conjugué avec le discours des géologues
pétroliers sur ce qu'il allait advenir
au ce qui va advenir de la production de
pétrole
il ya quelques années vous vous aurez
naturellement conduit à vous poser la
question qui est à quel moment as qu'il
faut que je bascule vers des voitures
qui vont être plus petit a certes elles
vont m'apporter - mais en attendant je
continue on va peut-être aller vendre
alors que les grosses je les vends vrai
plus difficilement c'est bien ça la
question qui est posée alors pourquoi
est-ce que ça a un sens de poser cette
question parce que quand vous êtes en
entreprise quand vous êtes dans une
collectivité
quand vous êtes dans le débat public
vous avez deux manières m'intéressait la
population à la question du changement
climatique et à la question des énergies
fossiles
la première manière c'est de les faire
passer parce que vous avez enduré depuis
un mois et demi et une fois que les gens
ont compris en cette fois deux heures
est en fait en beaucoup plus que ça ce
qu'était le changement climatique et ce
qu'était la contrainte sur les énergies
fossiles
allez vous leur dites qu'il faut passer
à l'action et puis il ya une deuxième
manière qui va beaucoup plus vite qui
est de traduire tout ça en argent parce
que ça les gens comprennent même s'ils
sont pas passer par l'étape
intermédiaire qui est d'avoir tout
compris sur la question des combustibles
fossiles et du changement climatique
donc à partir du moment où vous dites un
chef d'entreprise à partir de votre
bilan carbone je commence à avoir une
idée de vos points de vulnérabilité
économique
c'est quelque chose qui est c'est normal
va l'intéresser beaucoup plus que une
formation approfondie sur la géologie
pétrolières ou sur les raies
d'absorption du co2 dans l'infrarouge
donc ce genre d'exercice ça permet de
ramener la question du changement
climatique et des ressources en
combustibles fossiles limité sur le
terrain économique et le terrain
économique
il n'est rien d'autre que une base de
comparaison qui permet de
on parler de tas de choses qui
normalement ne devrait pas être
comparables puisque il ya entre un
ordinateur une carotte c'est pas
exactement la même chose physiquement
pourtant les deux ont un prix et donc un
prix
donc le prix c'est très exactement ce
qui a été conçu pour permettre de
comparer des tas de trucs qui sont pas
comparables contre une carotte et votre
scolarité
c'est difficile de comparer en attendant
les deux ont appris bon voilà c'est très
exactement pareil on va se ramener un
prix ou plus exactement un surcoût
possible alors voilà ce que ça donne ce
genre de choses là j'ai appliqué une
simulation économique
un bilan carbone données est ce que ça
dit cette affaire c'est que si le baril
bond de 60 à 100 dollars ça c'est un
truc que je vais faire un moment où les
gens disaient semble 100 $ vous n'y
pensez pas eh bien le l'énergie
d'utilisation de par exemple 1 du parc
du parc industriel de machines
industrielles augmentent de allez on va
dire cinq cent mille euros
l'utilisation la fabrication des
matériaux qui sont utilisés par cette
entreprise augmente de 2 millions
d'euros
ça veut dire que en gros les gens qui
ont produit les matériaux qui sont
nécessaires à cette entreprise
s'il répercute à lire les rues les
surcoûts qui ont eu lieu pour eux parce
que les combustibles se sont mis à
valoir plus cher
eh bien ils vont facturer à cette
entreprise 2 millions d'euros de plus
pour le revendre et même produire une
quantité
c'est une autre manière de dire que dans
un monde dans lequel le prix de
l'énergie augmentent les déplacements
économique que vous allez observer ne
seront pas limités à la facture de gaz
ou un facture de fioul ou à la facture
d'électricité que les gens vont payer en
direct ça va s'appliquer à tout le
système de prix puisque l'énergie est
absolument partout et est nécessaire
pour fabriquer absolument n'importe quoi
donc dans un monde dans lequel le prix
de l'énergie se met à augmenter de
manière significative
tout absolument tout d'avoir son prix
changer absolument tout et c'est très
exactement
l'enseignement que vous avez sur ce
graphique alors bien évidemment ça n'a
pas de valeur prédictive ce genre de
choses
c'est pas destiné à donner un à un
qu'est ce que je veux dire une
indication pas de prévisions par contre
ça vous donne un avis de grandeur de ce
qui est en jeu aussi
c'est une analyse de risques d'une
certaine manière ça peut également vous
permettre de parler argent quand vous
parlez bilan carbone d'arrivée
l'aberration qui sont des ratios
monétaire alors là il s'agit pas d'une
estimation de ce qui se passe si le prix
de l'énergie augmentent
il s'agit d'un ratio que vous faites en
sortie de but dans carbone pour regarder
un peu où vous situez alors vous êtes un
prestataire de services voilà je crois
une agence de pub comme ça et bien le
contenu carbone de votre activité
ramener à votre route chiffre d'affaires
va aller se balader en général aux
alentours de 30 grandes ça peut être ça
peut être 40 ça dépend des cas de figure
vous êtes une activité où vous n'avez
que des gens dans un bureau aux
architectes avocats
ma profession typiquement et c'est à ce
moment vous êtes plutôt aux alentours de
10 vous êtes dans l'industrie
manufacturière vous êtes plutôt aux
alentours de 100 donc vous vendez des
objets qui se touchent
qu'il s'agisse
de de plomb ou de chaises rouges
pourquoi vous prenez un neveu de
produits économiques en france en
moyenne
ça fait 75 grammes équivalent carbone
est là où on commence à rigoler c'est
que c'est la traduction de mon équation
de kaya de l'autre jour
si vous voulez avoir à la fois le
facteur 4 sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et en particulier de co2
en france et la croissance économique
ça veut dire que en quelques dizaines
d'années il faut passer de 75 grammes de
carbone
enfin équivalent carbone par euros de
pib à 7,5
donc en gros il faut faire une division
par dix je vous voyais ça veut dire que
n'importe quel objet fabriqué doit avoir
un contenu carbone qui est intérieure à
haut contenu carbone actuel de gens qui
sont assis dans un bureau c'est ça que
ça signifie avec juste un petit bout
d'ordinateurs et c'est tout voilà je
pense que ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui vous illustre ce qu'on peut avoir
comme raisonnement ou comme type d'
approche quand ton mari à la fois le
carbone raison alors on peut faire
exactement le même genre de jeu avec la
taxe carbone c'est à dire un signal prix
qu'on mettrait sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre pour placer exactement
pareil
vous imaginez que on applique une taxe
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
les cependant la question c'est quid
pour celui qui est en bout de chaîne
alors vous avez la possibilité de mettre
des taxes mais vous avez aussi la
possibilité de mettre deux types de
mécanismes économiques comme je le
disais tout à l'heure qui ont qui ce qui
matérialise un coût pour l'utilisateur
même si ce n'est pas directement des
taxes
quant à une norme c'est un coût pour
l'utilisateur indre et bonce a peut être
un coût pour l'utilisateur à quotas ça
peut être un coût pour l'utilisateur et
c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas confondre
c'est ce qu'on appelle actuellement le
prix du co2 sur le marché qui est en
fait quelque chose de très particulier
dangereux est un tout petit peu vous
parlez
la taxe le prix du co2 sur le marché
correspond à un prix d'un objet très
particulier qui est les changes entre
sociétés qui sont soumises à des quotas
dont je vous ai déjà parlé des
obligations dont les uns n'ont pas usage
et dont les autres ont usage
un jour à peine ce que c'est qu'un
système de quotas c'est un système de
tickets de rationnement négociable donc
si vous êtes tous des chefs d'entreprise
dans la salle et que vous avez tous des
usines qui émettent du co2 eh bien je
donne à chacun d'entre vous un droit
d'émission et à ce moment le droit
d'émission de vous n'avez pas besoin
parce que votre usine cette année-là a
émis moins que le droit que je vous ai
donné
et bien la partie que vous n'avez pas
utilisé vous avez droit de la vendre à
un de vos copains
moyennant un prix que vous convenez de
gré à gré pour que lui ou elle satisfait
à ses obligations parce que son usine à
eni plus que le droit que je lui ai
donné un c'est sale c'est ça l'idée et
bien ce prix qui est négocié de gré à
gré sur un marché c'est ça qu'on appelle
classiquement aujourd'hui le prix de la
tonne de co2 c'est pas une taxe c'est à
prix de marché sur une fraction
marginale des émissions qui est celle
qui ne sont pas nécessaires à des gens
qui ont des obligations et qu'ils vont
vendre à d'autres personnes qui ont les
mêmes obligations et qui en ont besoin
c'est ça qu'on appelle le prix du co2
cela rien à voir avec une taxe une taxe
est à la première tonne que vous émettez
je vous demande de payer tort et je vous
demande pas de les payer à votre
bronzage de vous demande de les payer à
moi percepteur des impôts
c'est un système qui n'est absolument
pas le même
alors on peut faire un système mixte
dans lequel je vais aux enchères mois le
percepteur des impôts les tonnes de co2
dont vous avez besoin
donc vous avez tous des usines et au
début de l'heure de cours jeudi mais
voilà j'ai des tonnes de co2 à voir qui
en veut dans ce débat je les prends à
3,015 moi j'ai proposé au 53 rue puteaux
où les données alors et moi je les
prends à 4 euros et moi et c'est donc ça
c'est un système mixte dans lequel les
droits de m ne sont plus attribués
gratuitement mais ils sont mis aux
enchères où ils peuvent être attribuées
contraint le paiement d'une redevance
forfaitaire à ce moment vous retomber
dans un système de quasi taxes etc
donc quand je dis taxes ici en fait je
devrais dire plus généralement manif
otages
coût des émissions à travers des tas de
mécanismes qui peuvent faire appel
de manière plus ou moins en proportion
variable à ou bien un prix qui est égale
pour tous
ou bien à des prix qui sont différenciés
avec éventuellement des franchises mais
enfin le mécanisme général est le même
alors est-ce qu'une taxe est quelque
chose qui est vraisemblable il ya des
endroits où ça commence à être appliquée
la colombie britannique a décidé
d'appliquer ça y'a pas longtemps
la californie a décidé de mettre en
place un système de cette nature il ya
pas longtemps des pays scandinaves ont
mis en place ce genre de système il ya
quelques années
la france est en train de se taper pour
le moment pour savoir si elle va mettre
ça en place
alors pour le moment notre président à
tous il a plutôt décidé que ça lui
plaisait pas mais enfin bon
les temps vont probablement changé donc
c'est un sujet qui reste d'actualité
une fois que je vous ai dit tout ça je
vais faire la transition sur le quart
d'heure dont il avait été question sur
et vous dans tout ça c'est à dire où
sont les métiers de demain où une partie
des métiers de demain
dans le contexte que je vous ai posé
l'explosion alors pour aborder cette
question qui évidemment vous intéresse
enfin j'espère de manière un tout petit
peu structurée je vais partir de mon
équation favorite
c'est à dire l'équation de kaya dont je
désire parler parce que finalement elle
permet de structurer une bonne partie de
la discussion
tel que vous êtes formé telles que
l'esprit de l'ingénieur souffle ici la
chaise dans laquelle vous vous dirigez
huriez le plus naturellement dans ce
genre de contexte
c'est ce que j'ai mis dans le chapeau
intensité énergétique de l'économie donc
par exemple vous allez rentrer chez un
industriel qui va vous demander
d'optimiser son four d'optimiser sa
logistique d'optimiser un certain nombre
de trucs qui consomment de l'énergie
pour que ça en consomme moins à
production identique
vous pouvez éventuellement rentrer
un constructeur de bâtiments qui va vous
demander de mettre au point des offres
qui peuvent permettre d'isoler les
bâtiments pour pas trop cher et de faire
faire ainsi aux gens des économies de
charges
derrière vous pouvez commencer à vous
pencher sur la question de la
modification des déplacements alors ça
peut concerner à la fois la mise au
point d'un téléphérique peau de couette
qui permet de traverser grenoble par la
voie des airs de manière beaucoup plus
efficace sur le plan énergétique
ou bien ça peut concerner la mise au
point d'un logiciel qui permet aux gens
qui ont envie de faire du covoiturage de
se rencontrer ou bien vous pouvez
imaginer un système de parking à vélos
qui remplace instantanément les parkings
voitures ou bien on vous pouvez imaginer
des choses techniques et puis vous
pouvez aussi imaginer des choses social
est en fait vous allez vous rendre
compte que dans le métier de l'ingénieur
avec les années vous allez de plus en
plus dérivé de la technique vers le
social c'est à dire de la technique pure
et dure vers la gestion d'un système
dans lequel les hommes et c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
occupe une place prépondérante et puis
je dirais que une fois que vous
connaissez un secteur ou un métier ou un
objet ou les trois à la fois on peut
vous demander un certain nombre de gens
le font de repenser une organisation
d'une manière plus large
on reste quand même quelques par bach
améliorer l'efficacité de quelque chose
qui attaque fort bien on reste quelque
part dans l'amélioration de l'efficacité
de l'économie au sens
classique du terme après il ya un autre
pan qui va être très naturel pour vous
c'est à dire par exemple si les
centrales à charbon ça fait trop de co2
allons donc faire des centrales qui
fonctionnent avec ou du vent ou de l'eau
ou des noyaux d'uranium
bon ça c'est une autre filière où on se
dit que classiquement il derrière des
choses à faire
alors ça c'est évident qu'il va y avoir
un appel d'air et ça c'est évident qu'il
va y avoir un appel d'air alors
maintenant à quel type de métier en
particulier ça correspond à des métiers
qui peuvent très bien aujourd'hui ne pas
être qualifié de développement durable
sauf que quand vous regardez bien les
choses ça en est c'est à dire que c'est
des métiers qui permettrait ou qui
permettront normalement à la communauté
des hommes de passer de manière plus
agréable la transition dont je vous ai
parlé depuis quelques semaines après il
peut y avoir des métiers qui deviennent
un peu plus exotique par exemple se
poser la question les indicateurs qu'on
doit utiliser
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure le bilan
carbone finalement force a commencé à
réfléchir avec un indicateur qui n'est
pas d'abord physique qui n'est pas
d'abord économique pardon mais qui est
d'abord physique est bien la question
des indicateurs est souvent un point
absolument central dans la conduite des
organisations vous sortez probablement
de lycées ou l'un des indicateurs qui
était utilisée n'était pas un indicateur
strictement économique mais était le
taux de réussite au bac
voilà ça c'est un indicateur que les
proviseurs de lycées aime bien regarder
et il considère que c'est approprié pour
la conduite de leurs établissements
scolaires dans le monde dans lequel nous
avons vécu jusqu'à maintenant
qui était donc un monde essentiellement
en expansion on avait des indicateurs
que nous utilisions et qu'il faisait
sens dans ce monde là probablement qu'un
certain nombre de ces indicateurs ne
faut pas être appropriées pour les
quelques dizaines d'années qui viennent
et après en trouver d'autres
ça ça peut aussi faire partie des
métiers intéressants dans cette affaire
encore une fois le bilan carbone en est
un exemple
et vous pouvez en avoir des tas d'autres
après vous commencez à avoir deux
métiers qui sont aussi dans finalement
la logique du développement durable sauf
que c'est plus éloigné de l'idée que
vous pouvez en avoir dans la fonction de
l'ingénieur qui est par exemple d'éviter
que les gens en face 25 enfants pour en
faire votre malheur donc c'est une
question qui est doux ça c'est une
question qui est évidemment très
sensible
ça fait des siècles que cette question
est très sensible et vous savez que
malthus avait fait scandale en son temps
ne pas parce que il avait annoncé que la
population humaine serait limitée par
les ressources que la terre peut nous
procurer et ça c'est évidemment une
évidence mais parce que malthus avait
expliqué que des délais pour un été
paradoxalement et encore une fois je
vous conseille quand dira je vous je
vous laisse l'entière liberté d'en
penser ce que vous voulez malthus avait
fait scandale en disant qu'il fallait
surtout pas aidé les cours parce que
finalement ça n'était que repousser le
malheur d'une échéance en multipliant
encore plus le nombre de gens dans la
détresse
en gros ce que disait malthus sait si on
aide les pauvres ou en faire plein
d'enfants et comme ces enfants ils
n'auront pas les moyens de subvenir à
leurs besoins
eh bien ça à faire encore plus de
malheureux que si on les avait pas aidés
alors il faut se re penser il faut il
faut cependant se resituer dans le
contexte dans lequel malthus a écrit son
bouquin un malthus écrit son bouquin il
ya deux siècles
il est évident que les moyens de venir
en aide aux gens qui était à l'époque
dans la détresse n'était pas exactement
ce qui existe aujourd'hui
le contexte social n'était pas du tout
de même le système politique n'était pas
du tout le même
mais en attendant c'était une vraie
question qu'il avait posée c'est à dire
finalement quelle est la bonne manière
d'optimiser ou de minimiser le nom de
gens malheureux c'est ma question il
avait apporté une réponse qui n'était
pas une réponse très sympathique
peut-être mais en attendant c'est à ça
que alors pourquoi est ce que je vous
dis ce genre de choses parce que dans
les métiers dits du développement
durable vous allez en permanence vouloir
t
à des représentations du monde que les
gens en face de vous considère comme
étant bonne et que vous vous considérez
peut-être pas comme étant bonne et il ya
un certain nombre de débats difficiles
qui va prendre place là-dedans
par exemple toujours pour vous provoquer
un peu mais ça mérite réflexion
est ce que c'est un scandale d'une
personne de 90 cents heures pendant une
vague de chaud est ce que c'est un
scandale un certain nombre de gens
considèrent que oui à voir les réactions
de la presse à la suite de la canicule
de 2003 un certain nombre de gens ont
considéré que oui moi je pense que c'est
une question qui se pose vraiment parce
que finalement à partir du moment où on
considère que de mourir est un scandale
il n'ya qu'une seule solution c'est de
viser et l'immortalité
mais bon pour le moment ce n'est pas une
solution très opérationnels et si on
considère que l'immortalité n'est pas
une option
un accablement
la question vient sur la table qui est
c'est quoi la bonne manière de mourir et
c'est paul bonnefond mourir donc vous
allez à partir du moment où cette
affaire-là est en termes de l'équation
vous ne couperez pas dans les métiers du
développement durable entre guillemets
et dans les questions qu'on se pose
quand on réfléchit à l'avenir de la
civilisation humaine
vous ne couperez pas à des débats dans
lesquels il ya pas de réponse évidente
vous n'y couperez pas un c'est à la fois
ce qui peut en faire le charme et ce
qu'il peut en faire la difficulté il
faudra toujours se demander si c'est
légitime pas légitime de poser la
question et si c'est légitime ou pas
légitime d'apporter
un point de vue sur la question quand
vous faites de la comptabilité carbone
va vous allez par exemple toucher aux
trois premiers termes de votre équation
vous touchez très peu au dernier c'est
évident vous pouvez difficilement
conseillé à une entreprise de diminuer
son empreinte carbone en zigouillant la
moitié de ses salariés
voilà mais par contre vous toucher à
tout le reste puisque vous allez toucher
à la fois aux types d'énergie qu'elles
utilisent au type de produits qu'elle
fabrique à la consommation ça suppose et
aux indicateurs qu'il faut qu'elle
utilise et à savoir quel est le bon
indicateur alors il ya d'autres métiers
dans le développement durable que je
pourrais qualifier de manière un peu
provocante de greenwashing
vous savez le greenwashing c'est un
terme qui a été mis au point par les
anglo saxons et qui consiste à repeindre
en vert des trucs qui vont absolument
pas durer ça consiste à dire voilà je
suis quelqu'un je me préoccupe d'un
certain nombre de choses donc du coup je
suis durable alors dans le greenwashing
vous allez trouver quelques
embranchements un premier embranchement
c'est l'embranchement allègre c'est à
dire expliqué que le problème n'existe
pas
vous avez un certain nombre de gens qui
ont été payées dans un certain nombre
d'endroits pour s'occuper pour faire du
développement durable avec cette
interprétation là une deuxième manière
de faire du greenwashing c'est de dire
le point m existe mais il est totalement
sous contrôle
alors qu'en fait quand vous regardez les
choses un peu en détail il n'est
absolument pas un exemple pourrait être
de dire le problème existe mais il est
sous contrôle
quand je suis un fabricant de voitures
qui consomment du litre aux cent et que
je m'adresse à mes actionnaires qui sont
intimement persuadés que le brave à
monter à 500 dollars bon il est évident
que si leur dis ça je leur raconte des
salades et enfin vous pouvez aussi faire
preuve d'une myopie sélective dans ce
genre de cas de figure c'est à dire de
ne publier que l'indicateur qui vous
arrange
en oubliant bien évidemment celui qui
vous arrangent moins ça fait aussi
partie des métiers du développement
durable si vous allez au jeu
nuit dans un certain nombre d'endroits
de direction du développement durable ou
de sociétés prestataires dans ce domaine
là vous allez trouver des gens qui
peuvent regarder bien sont dans cette
liste là alors je vous reprends le petit
diagramme que je vous avais montré en
des temps plus anciens peuvent nous
expliquer par exemple qu'en ce qui
concerne les indicateurs est bien un des
métiers qui peut être fait les gens qui
derrière des études scientifiques
deviennent économistes y en a
quelques-uns et bien en fait il se pose
la question de savoir comment on peut
passer d'un flux annuel à un compte de
résultat voilà typiquement le genre de
choses que vous pouvez avoir affaire
dont bon nombre d'endroits ça ça peut
être fait dans un inventeur de recherche
par exemple alors ça peut vous paraître
très exotique
il n'empêche que aujourd'hui vous avez
une commission qui a été mise en place
en france qui est coprésidé par deux
prix nobel d'économie et qui a très
exactement ça dans son cahier des
charges
c'est à dire la question qu'on leur a
posé c'est par quoi peut-on remplacer
pays d c'est très exactement ça la
question qu'on leur a posé les deux prix
nobel d'économie en question c'est
monsieur stiglitz et monsieur scène
toujours bas les métiers du
développement durable vous allez trouver
après les activités qui ne concerne pas
la partie co2 des émissions donc la
partie combustibles fossiles ou la
partie émissions de co2 en aval mais qui
concerne non excusera qui concerne pas
l'activité industrielle mais qui
concerne l'agriculture et la
déforestation évitée la déforestation
c'est à l'évidence une activité qui
participent au développement durable
parce que vous allez éviter de mettre du
co2 dans l'air et vous allez également
préservé des milieux qui sont des
réservoirs intéressant de tout un tas de
bestioles vous allez retomber sur des
questions très difficiles
il était évident que tous les gens qui
s'intéressent aux moyens d'éviter la
déforestation ne coupe pas à des débats
de
sur la question démographique je vous
avais déjà dit que la déforestation
c'était sous les tropiques la
reproduction d'un phénomène qu'on a
connue en europe qui était que
l'expansion démographique avait conduit
la population à abattre les arbres pour
créer des champs et c'est à peu de
choses près ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui dans les pays dans
lesquels il ya de la déforestation
même si ses chansons en fête des
plantations de palmiers à une qui
servent à produire de l'huile pour les
occidentaux
1 c'est toujours des activités agricoles
éviter la déforestation vous allez
retomber sur ce problème douloureux de
la démographie qui est encore une fois à
des termes de l'équation
une des questions donc par exemple c'est
que les moyens de persuader les gens qui
ne sont pas plus malheureux avec deux
enfants qu'avec 8 c'est une vraie
question
et c'est un vrai défi et c'est souvent
un défi beaucoup plus difficile à
relever que de savoir comment est ce
qu'on fait un boulon 2 avec un tout
petit peu moins d'acier vous allez avoir
un deuxième
une deuxième catégorie souvent la
question de la déforestation dans ce
genre d'endroit ne tient pas tant à des
procédés techniques que à ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des règles de
gouvernance
donc si vous voulez travailler dans le
domaine ça veut dire qu'il faut se
pencher sur des questions quand même
c'est quoi les bonnes règles de
propriété foncière
est-ce que les gens qui ont le terrain
sont libres de faire ce qu'ils veulent
chez eux ou est-ce qu'on doit encadrer
la manière dont il gère les terrains
dont ils sont propriétaires etc
comment est-ce que l'on tient à bon
cadastre pour la savoir à peu près ce
qui se passe vous allez également tombés
sur des considérations agronomique
il est évident que si on peut tripler le
rendement des cultures sans inconvénient
environnementaux et bien à toutes choses
égales par ailleurs vous avez besoin de
trois fois moins de terres agricoles
donc ça en laisse plus de livres pour y
mettre de la forêt ou autre chose
et puis vous allez également vous
pencher sur la question des régimes
alimentaires puisque comme je voulais
déjà expliqué il faut considérablement
plus de surfaces agricoles pour manger
de la viande et en particulier de la
viande rouge est que pour manger dit
demant des céréales ou des produits
végétaux donc là c'est pareil
la question du régime alimentaire et
quelques choix donc persuader les gens
qui ont peut être tout aussi heureux en
mangeant au moins deux boeufs
c'est un métier qui participe du
développement durable entre guillemets
puisque ça revient à soulager la
pression de l'agriculture au sens large
vous pouvez encore vous pencher sur
l'efficacité des petits poils ou des
petits foyer à bois qui sont à
combustion ouverte qui sont utilisés
dans bon nombre de pays pour faire la
cuisine avec des rendements qui sont pas
bons du tout donc peut-être que ça vaut
le coup pour éviter de la déforestation
de distribuer gratuitement des petits
butagaz dans un certain nombre
d'endroits où de faire payer pas cher
parce que finalement les petites
émissions du butane et du propane vont
être très inférieure aux grosses
démission de la forêt qu'on a coupé et
puis vous allez éventuellement dans les
métiers du développement durable trouver
de la finance on va même souvent trouvé
de la finance alors ici je vous la donne
en exemple pour la déforestation ou plus
exactement les moyens d'éviter la
déforestation
parce qu il est bien évident que la
population qui habite à côté des forêts
qui sont en train d'être coupée elle
elle a une équation économique en tête
qui est est ce que la valeur de ma forêt
sur pied est supérieure ou inférieure à
la valeur de ma foi aurait coupé et s'il
hectares de terres défrichées il a une
valeur économique supérieure
actuellement à l'hectare de forêt sur
pied parce qu'avec de la foire est
défriché suis incapable de vendre le
bois 2 capable d'avoir les activités
agricoles avec un fond et sur pied je
vois là j'ai juste un peu de bois de
temps en temps eh bien il est évident
que la coupe est donc les mécanismes de
financement c'est qu'est-ce que je fais
comme transfert entre les gens qui
veulent que la forêt reste debout mais
qui habite pas à côté et les gens qui
habitent à côté et qui la coupe pour
essayer de leur donner envie de faire
autre chose que couper la forêt ça c'est
un exemple particulier mais en fait vous
allez vous rendre compte que les
mécanismes économiques en jeu
les mécanismes de financement en jeu
sont souvent des trucs qui sont au
centre des changements dans les
organisations et des changements dans
les techniques employées
il suffit pas d'avoir une bonne active
une bonne idée technique encore une fois
pour que nécessairement elle diffuse
tout seul en fait je finirai par ça en
ce qui concerne les émissions de
l'agriculture là vous allez retombées
aussi sur les régimes alimentaires donc
par exemple un métier du développement
durable ça peut être de travailler dans
un restaurant d'entreprise ou dans une
cantine scolaire en vous posant la
question comment est ce que je fais pour
que les gens ils s'arrêtent pas
automatiquement devant l'assiette de
steak frites et qui acceptent de
s'arrêter devant autre chose donc là
vous voyez que on ne touche pas
seulement à des questions techniques
on touche aussi l étape trucs qui n'ont
plus rien à voir vous pouvez également
travailler alors là on peut remonter sur
la technique
vous pouvez travailler sur la
fabrication des amendements c'est à dire
les engrais ou sur la quantité qui est
utilisée ou sur les variétés culturales
qui sont utilisés parce que ça nécessite
plus ou moins d'engrais ou sur la
rotation des cultures parce qu'il ya des
manières de s'y prendre dans la rotation
des cultures qui permettent d'avoir
moins d'engrais et moins de
phytosanitaires pour des mêmes
rendements vous pouvez éventuellement
travailler aussi alors ça faut avoir les
narines solide mais vous pouvez
travailler dans des systèmes qui
permettent de mieux gérer les effluents
animaux donc le purin et lisier pour que
ça ait net - de protoxyde d'azoté moins
de méthane surtout voilà donc là vous
pouvez retomber dans des sociétés je
pourrais qualifier d'industriels vous
pouvez savoir quel est le truc que vous
devez faire à manger aux vaches pour
qu'elle mette à nice - ça aussi simple
est un vrai sujet voilà ça chante la
riziculture est également une source
significative des émissions de méthane
vous pouvez aussi vous poser la question
de savoir comment est ce que je fais
pour diffuser des pratiques culturales
qui consisterait à cultiver du riz sec 1
ce qu'on peut faire voilà donc ce petit
panorama que je viens de vous montrer
vocation de vous faire comprendre qu'il
n'ya pas
métier dans ce genre de domaine ya
finalement autant de métiers que il y a
de manière de tenter de répondre à la
question qui est comment est-ce que je
rend les gens heureux avec moins de
combustibles fossiles et moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
voilà il y en aura énormément selon le
temps une fois vous savez ça il reste
encore quelques petites choses à savoir
la première c'est qu'il suffit pas
d'avoir une bonne idée il faut aussi
trouver quelqu'un qui est prêt à vous
payer pour ça donc ça veut dire où
quelqu'un qui est prêt à vous donner le
job qui correspond à la bonne idée que
vous avez ou quelqu'un qui est prêt à
vous acheter le produit absolument
extraordinaire que vous avez mis au
point une deuxième chose qui vous sera
nécessaire pendant ces quelques heures
on a passé en revue des tas de phénomène
extrêmement compliqué il vous faudra
savoir les traduire de manière simple à
des gens qui n'auront pas le temps de
comprendre un titre qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps de vous écouter leur raconter les
choses compliquées et ça je peux vous
assurer que c'est une des plus grandes
barrières à l'entrée à la diffusion de
la révolution c'est clairement une des
plus grandes barrières à l'entrée
ensuite il suffit pas non plus de dire
y'a qu'à faut qu'on
il faut comprendre comment est-ce que
y'a qu'à faut qu'on se met en place et
comprendre comment il ya qu'à faut qu'on
se met en place vous amène souvent une
kyrielle de questions quand vous vous
rendez compte que aucune n'est
absolument trivial en ce qui concerne sa
réponse ensuite une forme que vous avez
les idées absolument clair il faut être
capable de convaincre les gens vous avez
en face de vous que c'est aussi dans
leur intérêt
donc il suffit pas de savoir expliqué
c'est à dire de sade expliquez-vous
votre intérieur vous lis faut aussi être
capable d'amener les gens vous avez en
face de vous à comprendre que c'est
aussi leur intérêt
et là aussi ça suppose une forme de
partage du bénéfice et qui n'est pas
toujours quelque chose d'évident à
mettre en place parce que souvent vous
allez déplacer un partage des bénéfices
préexistants et dans le nouveau partage
ya un certain nombre de gens qui peuvent
considérer que ça fait pas leur affaire
ensuite il ne faut pas être complètement
insensible à l'évolution du monde qui
vous entoure
donc il faut être capable de s'adapter
en temps réel j'allais dire à la
situation telle qu'elle se présente ça
c'est un truc est important pour les
ingénieurs
il ne suffit pas de penser que
l'important enfin traitement il ne
suffit pas d'avoir une bonne idée
encore une fois l'important c'est que
les autres soient persuadés aussi et
enfin si vous voulez avancer dans la vie
il ne faudra jamais avoir peur de poser
des questions vous ne pouvez pas savoir
le nombre de malentendus et d'impasse
qui peuvent arriver dans les
organisations d'adultes simplement parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont pas osé un
certain nombre de moments poser la
question qui aurait permis d'éviter on
veut pas avoir l'air ridicule repas en
avoir l'air de celui ou de celle qui
sait pas etc
d'autres posent pas la question il ya un
malentendu on part sur le malentendu est
derrière en fait au moment où les
conséquences du malentendu commence à se
matérialiser et bien le coût de remise
en état de la situation est
considérablement supérieur à celui qui a
été la conséquence de simplement poser
la question au bon moment voilà et sur
ce je vous donne rendez vous jeudi à
10h45 avec vos stylos et le copie
aujourd'hui